so what's CNN saying about all of this
well uh again they're coming around
because the truth is a Time release
capsule for mainstream media even the
economy to some extent you've heard
Biden say this is Putin's fault I think
that excuse is sort of uh wearing thin
with people across the board there is
this sense that he's not quite getting
where he needs to go so what do you do
if you're sitting at home you have a job
but you're kind of strapped by inflation
so what's the takeaway here what's the
long term you know what it's so
interesting because this time you know a
year ago the president could look at
these numbers and tout them and sort of
boast about them now that's completely
changed because the name of the game is
inflation you've got ordinary Americans
paying more in terms of higher gas
prices food prices even though they save
so much during that pandemic they're now
eating into those savings so buy-in is
going to obviously be blamed for this so
what's super interesting about this is
you guys know that this is all on Biden
like you don't have to be a wizard to
remember that in the four years under
the orange man the economy was going
bananas in a good banana sense it was a
good bunch of bananas okay things were
great black and Latino unemployment was
at an all-time low obviously coveted and
lockdowns and all of that mangled that
but the basic structure of the economy
the basic idea of lowering taxes
unleashing competition and businesses uh
getting businesses to return to America
all of those things it was all working
it really was all working you may not
have liked uh Donald Trump's skin color
and you may not have liked his hair and
some of the way he spoke in the tweets
but that is a fact then we elect this
human corpse who doesn't really stand
for anything other than he's been in
government for 47 years obviously never
really made anything happen otherwise
things would be better and there would
be no use for him to be president
obviously
his candidacy in many ways was an
complete exposure of the fact that Obama
didn't do a great job when it came to
anything systemic racism the economy
blah blah blah because that ushered in
Trump so then why'd we bring in Biden to
fix it doesn't make any sense even CNN
now is reporting that a lot of people
know something ain't right
as members of his own party and key
supporters are getting more frustrated
they're questioning if the White House
can muster the urgency to deal with huge
challenges from the economy to the
Supreme Court overturning Roe v Wade and
the rattle confidence is widespread a
Monmouth poll just found 88 percent of
Americans think the U.S is on the wrong
track that's an all-time low
okay that is a crazy
crazy number I I try not to get lost in
stats and polls and things like that
because they can be manipulated I
generally don't trust CNN and often the
polling organizations that they're using
the fact that CNN is putting that
statistic up 88 think that this country
is on their own track that's pretty much
everybody Biden now is running out of
excuses because every time he says it's
Putin's price hike the average person
now is realizing that hey that's just
it's just not true you're in charge of
this country so if a [ __ ] if a leader of
another country can just Jack our gas
prices up cause our inflation to go up
cause us to have supply chain issues and
all of those things if that is true well
then it is your job to make sure that
those things don't happen so nobody's
buying this Putin price hike thing
anymore but every now and again remember
he blames Putin for everything it's
always Putin but every now and again he
accidentally says something else
and when it comes to the gas prices
we're going through an incredible
transition that is taking place that God
willing when it's over will be stronger
and the world will be stronger and less
reliant on fossil fuels when this is
over
do you get the level of mixed messaging
that that is so on one hand the prices
are going up because of Putin Putin is a
bad dude he went into Ukraine it's
causing all gas prices to rise and he's
also always yelling at gas companies for
price gouging even though they're just
responding to the market okay they want
to make a profit they want to actually
put gas in people's cars and have people
come to their gas station there is some
level of competition that goes on there
but he's always blaming Putin for all of
this but then right there he says well
actually it's because we're going
through this transition we've got to get
off this stuff this is an incredible
opportunity and it's like man those
things are completely at odds with each
other completely at odd which is it man
is it that we need gas and but Putin's a
bad dude or is it that we're actually
doing it to ourselves because you guys
have your green New Deal and you're
trying to destroy the way the known
world was able to build itself over the
last say 100 years which one is it